- Now I have to ask one
Ghostbuster question.
(audience cheers)
- Right.
- Okay!
You guys, there's,
'cause I need to settle
whether or not this is true,
there's a rumor that there could be
(sing-song voice) a sequel coming.
- Yeah, yeah.
You know, there will be
another Ghostbusters.
(host yells in delight)
(audience cheers)
that I can definitely say, you know,
the last Ghostbusters was
very, thanks to all the fans.
They loved it.
And now we'll be making
another Ghostbusters.
(audience cheers)
- I love that.
I love that.
- And I'm happy to say that Winston,
the character I play is now a billionaire,
so he has a little bit more freedom.
(audience cheers)
- Well, come on!
I might see you on set.
All right.